pamela wrote in should it be easier to
qualify for Presidential Debates in
order to encourage more diversity of
ideas and breaking the two-party duopoly
I think the answer is yes right now the
requirements for being in the national
debates are that you need to be on the
ballot in enough states to get 270
electoral votes which would get you the
presidency and you need to be polling an
average of 15% in some number of recent
major polls I think that that's just too
restrictive and those are the rules that
the Republican and Democratic parties
have agreed to because they want to keep
other people out of the major debates
that's the whole point it is a system
designed by the two major parties to
keep control in the hands of the two
major parties so I think that the
threshold needs to be lower than 15
percent I don't know exactly what it
should be there are people who say it
should be 2 percent the problem with 2
percent is you might end up with 14
people on the stage and and that is not
going to be productive within our system
now I will say that if we had a
different voting system if we had
Instant Runoff voting for example I
think that the case for allowing people
into debates with even lower thresholds
is a stronger one but I'm kind of mixing
two different political issues here what
do you think I think a number right you
go to Pinto ain't you gotta cut people
off at some point yes 5 percent maybe
that's not about right that's what I'm
thinking yeah yeah what I mean total
affront to our democracy to that the
Republican and Democratic parties are
running these debates it used to be in
the hands of the weak League of Women
Voters for a while at least seemed
independent right yeah and the Federal
Elections Commission is just basically
they take direction from Republicans and
Democrats so I think that we are there's
a couple different things that are going
to allow us to break the two-party
duopoly if we ever were going to you've
got to bring down the threshold from 15%
I think being on the ballot and enough
states to win is perfectly reasonable
because if if you're not on the ballot
in enough states to win why are we
listening to you in a national
presidential debate you ever see in like
the primary races or like statewide
races if there's a candidate that really
doesn't have much of a chance they'll
give them less time yes
you think in the presidential setting
that that would be adequate or that
would make sense that's always tough
right I mean right and you go to the 17
person Republican primary debate and you
have some people who are polling 1%
should they get as much time as
everybody else it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy because part of
the reason that they will never get
beyond 1% is nobody asked them questions
but at the same time should you spend
even amounts of time when there are
three or four clear frontrunners
I opted for more fairness and more
democracy if the candidates that are
already doing better are doing better
because they're better candidates they
should be able to portray themselves as
the strongest candidates with the same
amount of time as the other candidates
so I'm in favor of giving the candidates
on the stage equal time you can decide
you can debate how you get on the stage
but I think if you're on the stage you
should absolutely get equal time